after six successful seasons fans of
shits Creek are preparing to say goodbye
to the eccentric and lovable Rose family
we knew that you were a very big fan of
the show we wanted to present you with
an honorary key the accolades the cast
had received over the years was
something even they had a hard time
comprehending it's almost kind of beyond
believe for what's happening the county
series has even made history with a
record-breaking 26 Canadian Screen Award
nominations that includes a nomination
for every member of the rose family when
one of us shines all of us shine that is
the meaning of ensemble we're just
thrilled that people are enjoying it
it's a wonderful thing and one of the
show's biggest fans is Eugene Levy's
American Pie co-star Alyson Hannigan oh
my gosh I love should create I am so sad
that it's coming to an end and the love
for shits Creek is contagious with other
Hollywood a-listers taking notice
including Jennifer Lawrence much to the
surprise of Dan and the rest of the cast
Jennifer Lawrence I love you I love that
see that's amazing
yeah but the show yeah Paula Abdul I'm
obsessed with Paul Rudd Catherine
O'Hara's character in shits Creek is is
quite possibly the greatest creation
since the Mars rovers it's something to
behold it's it's spectacular and Nicole
Kidman who couldn't help but ask the
cast for a photo at this year's Critics
Choice Awards
apparently Nicole Kidman is a fan of the
show so that I don't need to have one
tonight because I'll be framing that
in my office son for the end of time yes
see it was unbelievable but for Dan one
of the most unbelievable celebrity fans
was the one and only Mariah Carey who
tweeted that's not bleak watch shits
Creek here my Mariah Carey hey that
compliment could bring me to tears but
I'm not gonna let out a surprising tweet
dance spoke about with Stephen Colbert
on The Late Show it was more of like an
like an anxiety induced panic because I
didn't know how to physically manifest
the excitement or so I was just sort of
bottling it up inside sending people
text messages in all caps just saying
Mariah and they'd write back being like
what about her as the series comes to an
end it's memorable and laugh-out-loud
moments will hold a special place for
Canadians and fans around the world as
it's simply the best
[Music]